fourteen doors each one leading into a
room with a live work of art from the
gravity-defying performer of
shanghai-based zhu chen
to spanish artist santiago sierra and
his alienated veterans they were all
created by high profile artists
jennifer ayora and guillermo calzadia
have created a piece called revolving
door in which dancers rotate around the
room spontaneously
you have to focus on not being a person
in certain situations
you have to suppress your laughter when
funny situations arise you have to be
fully present
in one group somebody began to count
really loudly which created a difficult
situation for these performers because
they couldn't follow the rhythm
correctly
british artist damian hurst created this
installation called hans gayock in 1992
he seated identical twins in front of
his spot paintings stephanie and melanie
are among the rotating cast of twins for
this year's version
as are rafael and leonard
the works some of which are new others
that are old but have rarely been
performed all explore the relationship
between space
time
and physicality
and they can have varying impacts on
visitors to the exhibition
i had a feeling of voyeurism
which was unpleasant at the beginning
but then it turned into a sense of
fascination
in a fascination i think it's very um
breathtaking to see real humans as part
of the art because
it kind of connects with you on another
level especially when you make eye
contact with the performers my magnus is
a irritated
it's a bit confusing and disarming it
also causes a feeling of unpleasantness
it's not a commodity like other artists
what have we got here a clip
in his piece entitled swap slovakian
artist roman ondak asks performers to
choose an object to exchange with
visitors
a tube of hand cream
or a usb stick for example do you want a
swath
i really want you to swap that because
you found it on the street i think
that's wonderful
would you swap that for me yeah okay
thank you okay i have 20 subscribers
there we go i've got 20 subscribers
who'll give me 50 swiss ranks for that
people make artwork sometimes in the
room someone will draw a beautiful piece
of art or write a story or poem this is
a lovely way to engage children as well
often children are in the room so
to engage children we often get them to
do a drawing or something like this and
they'll exchange it
in ottawa's new work diaspora performers
have been given the challenging task of
balancing a plant called queen of the
night on their heads
there's some things that are structured
very structured and there's some things
that are left for improvisation
they know when they come into the room
this is where i stand but within that
they can improvise with the emotion of
the voice
it's the third installment of this
exhibition of live art performances in
basel the curators are hans ulrich
obrest co-director of london's
serpentine gallery and klaus biesenbach
director of moma ps1 in new york
three or four generations gathered here
show that live art has interested
artists for some time it was important
to us to bring them together here just
it's not just about art history it's
also about human life
i don't think visitors need any
expertise for this kind of exhibition
it's easy to perceive its radical nature
and yet it also has something to do with
art history
14 rooms an exhibition that adds a new
dimension to contemporary art running
now in basel through june 22nd
you